when you believe you've exhausted all
options
remember this you haven't no matter what
you choose to do there will always be
people who find fault with it
everyone should become rich famous and
achieve everything they want just to
realize that it's not the point
want to soar get a mentor
what's up believe nation its Abbot this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so today let's learn from one of
the best Jay Shetty on how to improve
your life and get massive success mentor
me Jay
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take responsibility just around two
years ago I had this idea I wanted to
share wisdom at a pace we wanted
entertainment I wanted to share wisdom
in a way that it could connect resonate
and deeply evolve the lives of people
all over the world for ten years before
that I'd been working with individuals
groups coaching at universities
companies and all of these opportunities
that I really wanted to serve and
connect with everyone across the world I
wanted to make wisdom accessible to
anyone who had one of these I'm not one
of those so I was excited I had the
energy the enthusiasm and I was pitching
my idea to every single company that was
online now remember this is before I
ever made a single video before any of
you knew who I was I applied to not 10
not 20 but 30 online media companies
hoping that one of them would like my
series idea I waited the day I waited
two days I waited a week I was rejected
by every single one of those companies
before interview
none of them invited me for a phone
interview none of them invited me for a
video interview none of them even
connected with me in any personal way
that's rude I said to myself it doesn't
matter let's see what else I can do to
try and make my goal a reality with
so I tried to network with people who
may be able to give me a chance I got
one on someone answering me they said
you're getting older now most of the
people who want to break into this
industry around 21 years old just don't
worry about it other people said to me
look you need to go get a media and
journalism degree or a masters and then
we'll take you seriously literally I was
getting rejected from every single
person I spoke to but inside of me I had
this desire had this calling I had this
mission I had this vision that I wanted
to share everything that I had learn
with people out there I genuinely tried
every single possible method I could to
break into the media industry to the
point that the only thing that was left
that I could try was to start a social
media channel and of course you know the
rest the most incredible thing is that
it reminds me of a really powerful
thought and Thomas Edison he once said
when you believe you've exhausted all
options remember this
you haven't bat for stayed in my mind
the whole time what I learned from all
of this rejection from all of this
failure from all of these clear knows
was one really important thing and today
I want to give that as a gift to you me
if you have a dream you have an idea you
have a vision we have to take the
responsibility to prove our worth before
we expect anyone to value our talent
when I started crafting and creating my
own videos teaching myself how to edit
learning how to produce understanding
the mechanics of social media when I
started putting my energy into that
space that's when people started to take
notice that's when people started to
listen
when things started to happen this is
nice it's when I decided to take the
responsibility for sharing what I was
passionate about with the world and not
waiting for someone external to validate
me or give me permission or allow me to
do that that's what made the difference
if you're feeling you've been going
through a lot of rejections ask yourself
this is your deeper passion and calling
making you want to move further number
two have you truly knocked on every
single door and number three are you
working hard on investing in your
expertise and passion so that you really
have something impactful to offer rule
number two know your element environment
and energy so for me my three e's are
element environment and energy every one
has an element that they thrive in if
you take someone out of it their element
they won't be the same modern-day
example would be Michael Jordan he was
incredible at basketball you took him at
a basketball put him into baseball no
one remembers his career we talked about
one the best athletes of all time your
environment is the environment around
you you can take a fish out of water and
give it a beautiful mansion and a
Bentley and all the money in the world
but it would die and that's what we are
like our environment everyone is an
environment which they thrive which we
have to craft your boss if you're at
work is never gonna ask you what
environment you succeed in right like
that never happens so we have to create
an environment where we thrive and then
finally it's energy we some of us love
high energy environments high pressure
some of us succeed in lower energy
environments and low pressure figuring
out your energy and the frequency on
which you operate best will help you
thrive as well so for me those are the
three e's to really create a thriving
environment know your element know your
environment and know your energy and so
on all times if I see anything going
wrong I'm going is my element out of
alignment is my environment out of
alignment or is my energy out of
alignment that's a great three question
test you can do to yourself when you
don't think things are going right and
all you have to do is bring that back
into alignment
three access your flow state flow or
flow state is defined as the optimal
state of consciousness when we perform
at our best feel at our best but also at
the same time ego falls away
time flies we're conscious but
subconsciously experiencing our own art
it's when we're fully immersed absorbed
and addicted to simply creating now I'm
sure you've all had moments when you
felt that whether you've been playing
sports and instrument traveling maybe
looking at a beautiful scenic view or
maybe just in a really engaging
conversation but I'm going to share with
you how we can experience more flow in
our lives because it heightens our sense
of joy or curiosity so the two variables
of flow are challenge
and ability and flow is with challenge
and ability collide or meet if your
answer to my question earlier is that
you often feel bored it's usually
because your skills are higher than your
challenge everything seems easy it's not
exciting anymore there's nothing new you
need to learn and you feel like you can
do things effortlessly but not in a way
that excites your empowers you but in a
way that almost drains you and makes you
feel more lethargic and lazy and part
let's say you're feeling more stressed
let's say you're feeling anxious let's
say you get nervous often that's usually
because the challenge is greater than
our skill the challenge has become so
high it feels like this massive mountain
that we're trying to climb and we feel
like we're completely carrying the
biggest weight on our shoulders and
therefore we're feeling the pressure
feeling the strain feeling that stress
in each of these scenarios what you're
seeing is a disconnect between your
challenge and your ability which is
either causing stress or boredom and
there's a really really simple solution
if you're feeling bored because your
skills are higher than your
Challenge well you need to do to make
life abundant exciting thrilling again
is raise your challenge try new
opportunities go into new arenas be new
environments meet new people
well that will force you to do is make
you raise your challenge which allow you
to grow and allow you to fly and if
you're finding that what you experience
more often than not is stress it's
pressure is pain then the way you combat
that is by increasing your skill level
try going on online courses learn from
mentors go on an apprenticeship see who
you can learn and be coached by and
guided by to improve your skills well
that will help you do is meet your
challenge with a higher skill set you
now be able to walk into a challenge
with confidence that you know how to
navigate the various things the
challenge will bring into your life flow
stay is this beautiful space where we
completely surrender to the art and
allow the energy to truly flow through
us it's something I've personally
experienced and want you to experience
in your life as well before stop caring
what others think you'll feel that
rejection kills dreams we all feel that
failure kills dreams we all feel that
people kill dreams you can't kill my
dreams but actually there's four words
that we say in our heads to ourselves
that genuinely have destroyed more
dreams than all of those things put
together those four words are what will
people say what will people say how many
times have you stopped yourself from
doing something because you're scared of
how people will react how many times out
of the fear of someone else's opinion or
criticism have you stopped yourself from
doing what you believe
how many times has someone's perception
or perspective stopped you from living
your potential no matter what you choose
to do there will always be people who
find fault with it there will always be
people who criticize complain you try to
bring you down and tell you that what
you're doing isn't right
haters gonna hate it's crazy that we
give up what we most want in life just
based on people's opinions and the crazy
thing is if we're living for other
people's opinions we'll never be right
there'll always be someone with
something that they won't agree with and
this is why it's so important that we
work with our own conviction we work on
what matters to us it was Aristotle who
told us that there were only three ways
to avoid criticism do nothing say
nothing really nothing and I'm sure none
of us want that of our future number
five focus on true wealth
I believe that wealth is beautiful and
brilliant it can do incredible things in
the world when used to make a difference
when we use any wealth that we have to
make an impact to use it to make an
influence to help serve and support the
lives of others but today I want to talk
to you about a different type of
richness there's more than one one of my
favorite teachings about wealth has been
this you can tell how rich you are by
counting the amount of things you have
that money cannot buy there's a
beautiful quote by Jim Carrey where he
says I believe that everyone should
become rich famous and achieve
everything they want just to realize
that it's not the point it would be nice
real wealth in a well fulfillment
satisfaction meaning and purpose is a
rich list that every single one of us
can have and beyond I want you to take a
moment to make a list of the things you
have
money cannot buy maybe it's a beautiful
family
maybe it's an incredible partner maybe
it's a passion and a drive that you've
recently found and discovered for
yourself maybe it's a recent experience
that you had there wasn't really about
where you were but more about who you
were with and what you were thinking
about the reason why I'm focusing on
this rich list is because this list is
something we often forget it's not on
the front page of a magazine it's not
inside the newspapers it's not on the
list online but this list is one that
you can look at every single day to
remind yourself how fortunate how
grateful and how incredible your life
truly is and rule number six the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
have a plan how many of you have a crazy
dream or a crazy goal I want you to
write out in the comments section what
is your crazy dream the dream that keeps
you up at night is the real dream you
should be chasing but to chase that
dream to find that dream to make that
dream a reality you need a strategy why
a dream without a plan is just a wish
Tony Robbins said that right a dream
without a plan is just a wish right
without a strategy without a guiding
philosophy without guiding principles
without actually creating a clear plan I
used to have this economics teacher and
I want you to think back to school as
well maybe you had one I remember this
economics teacher he walked in to the
classroom and the first thing that
you're on the board he didn't even tell
us his name we'd even know who he was
and he turned up he went inside the
classroom and he wrote on the board
he said failing to prepare is preparing
to fail and all of us just burst how
laughing this guy I don't even told us
his name yet but on the board he wrote
failing to prepare is preparing to fail
and now when I look back at that and as
I grew up and hopefully became a bit
more mature than I was in high school I
remember thinking about that statement I
thinking how true is that then when
you're not prepared for something you
miss out on believable opportunities now
I'm not saying good things don't happen
spontaneously sometimes things happen by
chance randomly etc with a reason but
when you're prepared you can capitalize
on things in a huge huge
wait I've got a really special bonus
clip from Jay on how to not let your
dreams die that I think you're gonna
real enjoy but before that it's time for
the three-point landing questions time
to move from just watch another video to
actually taking action in your business
and life so here we go question number
one what do you need to take more
responsibility for number two whose
opinion of you do you care about and
need to let go of and number three what
this true wealth mean to you
a wise person once said the tragedy of
life is not death but what we let die
inside of us while we're still alive we
think we're the victims but ideally we
should be the suspects because it seems
we've killed more dreams than rejection
we've given our ambitions a life long
sentence it's trapped deep inside of us
it makes no sense it's been locked for
so long we've even forgotten its name
everything we do today feels like it's
all the same our dream is like a
prisoner trapped within us a vacant
listener lacking all vision until
someone comes and says you don't see
your own potential it's like we all need
our own intervention a moment with a
mentor a coach or a guide the type that
sparks our light deep inside our minds
and then they ask us what's your passion
we shrug it off and say that stuff
doesn't happen and then they push us a
little further probe us to think deeper
they're always focused on helping us
find a hope inside of ourselves let me
ask you would you let someone who had
incredible potential died right next to
you he would never do that so why do we
let them die inside of it that's why the
missing link
a coach is someone who tells you what
you don't want to hear and as you see
what you don't want to see so you can be
you have always known you can be some of
us get given people some of us get given
lessons but all of us get given moments
to change the trajectory of our lives
we can't imagine Kobe Bryant without
Phil Jackson we can't imagine Serena
Williams without Patrick Mouratoglou we
can't imagine Tom Brady and now Alex
Guerrero it's not about what we take
it's about what we leave behind Maya
Angelou said people will forget what you
said they'll forget what you did but
they'll never forget how you made them
feel
Picasso said that the meaning of life is
to find your gift and the purpose of
life is to give it away coaches can be
found in books mentors can be found in
schools guides will be found throughout
life we don't have to be in the same
to understand their point of view we
don't have to know that for them to show
you the way we just have to have the
burning desire to learn behind every
great person is a coach that we may not
a name that may not recognize a face but
we may never see a lot of people have
gone further than they thought because
someone else for a lake
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people have passion can change the way
people not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your it's supposed to mean
if you guys want to learn more from Jay
check out the top 10 rows the success
video I did on him it's right next to me
I think you're gonna enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there
hey Evan and everyone watching thank you
so much for featuring my ideas and my
thoughts I've been following you for a
long long time